bonjour à tous bonne année oui bonne
année enfin on est les gens février
quand même alors aujourd'hui un épisode
un peu spécial vous n'avez pas pu le
manquer on en a parlé partout sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya quelques semaines
de quoi les vacances de blanc caire à
ibiza quoi mais non je pars de
l'anniversaire de la mort de pierre
bourdieu mais non mais personne parle de
ça
monsieur je pouvais pas faire un tour
sur facebook ou sur youtube pour voir un
truc sur le sujet est sérieux mais oui
même l'humanité a fait un numéro spécial
sur le sujet et sur le marché de pierre
bourdieu ses amis alexis corporelle
distinguer sa part été ben je crois
qu'on n'a pas le même internet peut-être
qu'on évolue juste pas dans le même
champ c'est une rafale bourdieu c'est ça
pardon je voudrais pas que tu te sens
dominé par mon capital culturel mais là
c'est mon habitude qui me titille waouh
je te préviens on va se calmer tout de
suite parce que je vais pas tenir une
vidéo entière comme ça oui tu as raison
donc pierre bourdieu est mort à 71 ans
le 23 janvier 2002 est donc le mois
dernier ça faisait tout pile 20 ans
qu'on déplorait sa mort c'est l'occasion
de lui rendre un petit hommage et de
revenir dans les grandes lignes sur la
figure incontournable qui est ce grand
monsieur de la sociologie
[Musique]
ouais
alors c'est toujours compliqué de
revenir en quelques minutes sur une
personnalité aussi complexe et
foisonnante que celle de pierre bourdieu
c'est une figure incontournable la
sociologie et on compte aussi bien des
adorateurs bea qui le voient comme un
messie que des critiques acerbes qu'ils
l'accusent d'avoir fait plus de mal que
de bien à la sociologie du coup bien
modestement parce que je suis loin
d'être un spécialiste je vais essayer de
mettre un petit coup de projecteur sur
sa vie ses inspirations théorique son
oeuvre et ses engagements à la fois
politique et scientifique
comme je viens de vous le dire je suis
loin d'être un spécialiste et en plus
j'ai écrit cette vidéo assez vite parce
que j'ai c'est de coller encore un petit
peu à l'actualité donc je ne m'interdis
pas éventuellement de refaire un petit
sujet hors série pour repréciser
certaines choses notamment peut-être
pour développer un petit peu la
postérité qu'il a eue dans les
différents courants sociologiques donc
si vous m'entendez dire une énormité ou
au contraire oublier un point qui vous
semblerait crucial et surtout n'hésitez
pas à l'espace commentaires est là pour
vous dans le respect et la bienveillance
par contre ça ça va de soi
[Musique]
alors la vie de bourdieu est
intéressante parce que sa sociologie va
être considérablement influencé par des
trucs qu'il a lui même vécu par exemple
quand il invente le concept de violence
symbolique dont j'ai déjà parlé dans cet
épisode m'a c'est quelque chose qu'il a
directement ressenti lui-même bon et
dont l'éventualité où l'on se remette
pas tes vieilles vidéos tous les deux
jours la violence symbolique tu nous
refait un petit topo ok la violence
symbolique c'est une forme de violence
indirects qui n'est pas perçue
directement mais qui est exercée par les
dominantes sur les dominer parce qu'ils
sont plus légitimes que même si bourg du
insiste sur le fait que ce souvent pour
des raisons complètement arbitraire
c'est l'exemple du type qui dans un
dîner mondain te demande quel est ton
oeuvre de ce ligne préférés et que tu te
doutes que sous le vent avec garou s'est
pas vraiment la réponse attendue et pim
violence symbolique dans ta face et
bourdieu il l'a vécu de première main
cette violence symbolique parce que lui
il vient d'un petit village rural des
pyrénées atlantiques son père c'est un
petit fonctionnaire des ptt et après le
lycée comme il était bon élève il va
être bombardé en classe préparatoire à
louis le grand à paris après il va
rentrer à l'école normale supérieure et
là il va côtoyer des gens qui viennent
plutôt d'un milieu social et
intellectuel élevé et il expliquera qui
sied jamais vraiment senti à sa place
d'où le ressenti de violence symbolique
et même jusqu'à la fin de sa vie en fait
il continuera paradoxalement à faire
preuve d'une certaine timidité alors
même qu'il est clairement l'ultime beau
gosse de sa discipline on le voit très
bien dans le film de pierre carles la
sociologie est un sport de combat sorti
en 2001 qui s'ouvre sur une prise de
parole que bourdieu doit faire en
anglais et il est littéralement paralysé
par le stress
mais si ça fait d'avoir un truc qui
m'échappe
mais c'est la sécurité la nuit six ans
redouble
on le verra mais pour dieu n'hésite
jamais à faire sa propre auto analyse et
le concept de violence symbolique semble
bien rendre compte de son sentiment
d'illégitimité qui peut se manifester
parfois par des sensations profondément
viscéral quand on vient d'un petit
milieu et d'un pays dominés on a
forcément de la honte une cure elle moi
j'avais la route où mon accent que
j'avais corrigée et sait c'est par
l'école normale quand je descendais dans
mon pays ça pierre cardin très bien
comprendre quand j'arrivais un dac ce
que j'entends et l'accent ça me faisait
horreur femme en colère encore
aujourd'hui j'entends certains accents à
la radio ça me fait physique maurer
alors avancé l'accent que j'avais
j'entends dernier radio j'entends les
tigana qui est un écrivain un chien qui
parle avec l'accent de brive j'ai envie
de me tuer ça me fait horreur pas
seulement parce qu'il dit c'est alors ça
c'est une forme voilà de violence
symbolique où la une a des petits soucis
d'agressivité le père bon dieu dans un
an je peux comprendre un moi aussi ça me
fait ça quand j'entends certains
politiques parler gérald darmanin par
exemple mais à cause de son accent ah
non non par contre rien à voir c'est
plutôt
c'est
disons stands tout quoi non mais calmez
vous madame cela bien se passer virez
moi ça sérieusement je commence à faire
de l'urticaire après l'école normale
notre pire au national va passer
l'agrégation de philosophie se loue
concours pour devenir professeur et il
commencera par enseigné au lycée avant
de devoir partir faire son service
militaire et il faut dire qu'à l'époque
on est en plein pendant la guerre
d'algérie alors ça rigole vraiment pas
avec le service militaire qui peut durer
jusqu'à 30 mois il sera affecté au
gouvernement général d'alger et c'est
pas du tout anodin dans sa biographie
parce que c'est en travaillant sur place
avec des statisticiens de l'insee qui
leva bifurquer vers la sociologie en se
formant à l'ethnologie au travail d
enquête il va même rester en algérie
pour poursuivre ses études entre 1958 et
1960 en faisant beaucoup de travail de
terrain et il publie ainsi son premier
livre en 1958 sociologie de l'algérie
dans la collection que sais-je et il
reviendra sur le sujet en 1964 avec le
déracinement la crise de l'agriculture
algérienne coécrit avec le sociologue
abdelmalek sayad et encore une fois plus
tard en 1972 avec sa fameuse esquisse
d'une théorie de la pratique précédé de
trois études d'ethnologie kabyle alors
l'expérience algérienne elle est
absolument pas anodine dans la vie de
bourdieu parce que la kabylie va
continuer toute sa vie a nourri son
oeuvre depuis l'étude comparative qu'il
fait en revenant dans son village natal
du béarn jusque dans ses écrits très
tardif comme la domination masculine en
1998 dans lequel il analyse les rapports
symbolique entre les hommes et les
femmes aussi bien dans notre société que
dans la société traditionnelle kabyle et
il faut souligner aussi que le contexte
d'apprentissage du métier des tno graf
en condition réelle va aussi lui
apporter très vite une très grande
expérience de l' enquête de terrain ça a
été re doublé par mon expérience de
l'algérie où j'ai donc fait des enquêtes
en situation dangereuse ou
oui selon je pense ça m a eu deux trois
fois selon la réponse que je donnais je
pouvais m'en tirer vivant ou mort quoi
bon là selon la manière de poser des
questions et je n'avais pas d'autres
protections d'associations de guerre
civile de guerre de guerre de libération
j'avais pas d'autre protection que ma
bonne tête et ma manière de me présenter
et de faire attention
et ça se voit et ça m'a beaucoup appris
beaucoup de choses qu'on lit dans les
méthodologies ont conduit pas d'arriver
nos mythologies parce que l'essentiel
n'est pas là j'ai appris comme ça
sa salle mais du plomb dans la cervelle
j'éviterai vite voilà c'est à dire
par rapport à un jeune sociologue qui
aurait fait sa petite enquête peinard
sur les profs et du coup j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes qui sont
ressortis de la tvq en brodant sur le
capital de problèmes que j'ai ramassé à
cette époque là
je crois a
évidemment à l'autre chose si moi
j'étais jaloux de sassafras je pense que
votre truc c'est ça fait très bien c'est
que j'ai eu l'idée comme je travaille
sur la kabylie et que je voyais beaucoup
d'analogies avec eux avec le béarn
les rapports entre les sexes et ça je me
suis dit pour ne pas utiliser mais mon
expérience de manière sauvage il faut
que j'aille étudier mon village comme
j'ai étudié la kabylie alors j'avais
j'avais deux objectifs d'abord de
contrôler cette expérience et puis aussi
de deux d'étudier ce que c'était que le
passé de l'expérience indigènes
l'expérience avant qu'est ce que ça fait
et alors je disais à l'époque c'était
une époque où de lévi strauss avait fait
tristes tropiques c'était le livre que
tout le monde disait c'est moi je vais
faire triste tropicale à anvers allez je
vais faire un retour
au lieu d'aller chercher très loin
chez
moi le moins exotique possible je vais
rendre exotique le banal comme vous
pouvez le voir il se pose déjà plusieurs
questions épistémologiques sur la façon
de passer de l'expérience au savoir
sociologique et c'est aussi une question
qui va l'accompagner tout au long de sa
vie alors la fin de sa vie je vous la
fait courte mais va publier près d'une
soixantaine de travaux sociologiques
dont certains vont être des blockbusters
aussi bien dans le champ académique pour
en large public et sa notoriété ne va
cesser de grandir jusqu'à ce qu il
occupe la chaire de sociologie au
collège de france de 1981 à 2001 soit
pratiquement jusqu'à sa mort la fin de
sa vie va également être marquée par un
engagement militant de plus en plus
prononcé et lui qui refusaient plutôt de
s'exprimer sur la place publique va
faire de plus en plus d'apparitions à la
télé même si parfois c'est sans grand
enthousiasme en fait je peux vous dire
j'ai vraiment eu sa part étonnant je
n'avais aucune envie de venir ici et j'y
viens il a d'ailleurs été pas mal
critiqué pour ça mais ça je reviendrai
un peu plus tard après avoir fait un
petit détour par son travail en
commençant par ses maîtres à penser
[Musique]
tout d'abord bourdieu il a bien lu c'est
classique de la sociologie et il va
s'inspirer de trois figures principales
mark webber est dur game alors déjà à
marx il va emprunter la vision de la
société comme étant le théâtre d'une
lutte entre des groupes sociaux aux
intérêts antagonistes marx voyait tout
l'espace social sont la seule dimension
économique avec d'un côté les
capitalistes qui possède les moyens de
production et de l'autre les prolétaires
qui n'ont que leur force de travail
bourdieu reprend ainsi l'idée d'une
société comme d'un espace de lutte pour
la domination à la différence près qu'il
va représenter l'espace social soupe
plusieurs dimensions et ça il va plutôt
aller le chercher c'est un autre
sociologue allemand max weber pour
waeber il y a trois grandes catégories
de stratification sociale il y a les
classes sociales sur le plan économique
les groupes statutaire qui dépendent du
prestige social et les partis qui
permettent l'accès au pouvoir politique
et ses trois dimensions ne se recoupent
pas complètement on peut avoir beaucoup
d'argent et pas de prestige où beaucoup
de prestige mais pas de pouvoir
politique ni spécialement d'argent un
grand écrivain ou un universitaire par
exemple il aura un statut élevé selon
l'ordre social mais plutôt bas selon
l'ordre économique ou politique
et du coup bourdieu va reprendre cette
analyse là pour développer la notion de
champ qui est sans doute l'un de ces
concepts les plus connus il emprunte ici
le vocabulaire de la physique l'idée
d'un champ magnétique pour montrer que
les individus sont tous pris dans des
rapports de domination mais dans
plusieurs champs sociaux différents
contrairement à webber qui voyait trois
ordre hiérarchique pour bourdieu il y a
un très grand nombre de champs et on n'a
pas besoin des mêmes compétences pour
être dominant dans le champ des traders
de crypto monnaie que dans le chant
grégorien l'a vu se faire un jeu de mots
avec chan chan déjà tu nous parles de
trucs un peu abstrait je te plaît et
vivent leur ajoute heures or ça va mais
c'est pas la seule chose que bourdieu va
retenir deux heures et il va aussi
prolonger sa réflexion sur le pouvoir et
sur la domination waeber est aussi connu
pour sa typologie des différentes formes
de domination charismatique
traditionnels ou rationnel légal mais il
avait surtout montré que les rapports de
domination sont aussi des rapports de
sens qui sont perçues comme légitime par
les acteurs et bourdieu il va notamment
beaucoup s'interroger sur les notions de
légitimité culturelle et sur pourquoi on
accepte comme légitime la culture des
catégories dominante est finalement bon
dieu va également lire avec attention le
père fondateur de la sociologie
française à savoir emile durkheim alors
il s'inspire de turckheim à la fois pour
son raisonnement aux listes à savoir
pour le fait qu'il considère que les
structures sociales s'impose aux
individus mais aussi pour sa méthode
telle qu'il l'a énoncé dans les règles
de la méthode sociologique en 1895 comme
dürckheim bourdieu à une vraie
prétention à l'objectivation il veut
faire de la sociologie une véritable
science turckheim insisté par exemple
sur l'importance pour le sociologue de
se défaire des prêts notion c'est à dire
des jugements de valeur que l'on peut
avoir sur tel ou tel phénomène pour les
analyser avec une certaine froideur
scientifique et de la même façon
bourdieu et passeron quand ils écrivent
le métier de sociologue en 1968 insiste
notamment sur la nécessité pour le
sociologue de rompre avec le sens commun
en disant qu'il faut pour cela faire
preuve d'une grande vigilance
épistémologique pour ne pas se laisser
contaminer par les préjugés qui viennent
de la société plus profondément c'est
tout l'ensemble des schèmes de pensée
utilise le sens commun pour rendre
compte de ses expériences sociales que
le sociologue risque toujours de laisser
s'introduire dans sa science et par
exemple
des le vocabulaire enfin charrie tout un
ensemble de
présupposés sociologique le sociologue
doit donc opposer une vigilance
particulière
contre tout les infiltrations du
discours commun et de l'expérience
commune alors si on peut trouver
aisément des lignes de filiation entre
bourdieu et ses prédécesseurs l'une de
ses particularités c'est qu'il fait en
fait assez peu référence au père
fondateur de la sociologie il donnera au
contraire souvent l'impression d'avoir
tout trouvé tout seul et même d'être un
peu le seul à faire de la vraie science
on peut comprendre que ça a énervé
certains de ses détracteurs d'autant
qu'il pouvait faire preuve d'une
certaine arrogance sur le sujet comment
peut longtemps dans cet extrait de radio
étant entendu que quand je dis science
jeudi qu' on peut me réfuté un examen
scientifique
jusqu'à présent j'étais l'objet d'
attaque jamais de réfutation au sens
rigoureux du terme je dirais que une des
raisons de ma tristesse enfin c'est que
dans le champ intellectuel français j'ai
beaucoup d'ennemis mais je n'ai pas
d'adversaire c'est à dire des gens qui
ferait le travail nécessaire pour
opposer une réfutation alors je sais que
ap un état on me répond mais ça c'est
totalitaire puisque vous êtes
irréfutable pas du tout pour me réfuté
il faut se lever de bonne heure il faut
travailler et ce pas avant clairement le
mec se prend pas pour la queue d'une
cerise effectivement non après on peut
pas leur reprocher de ne pas travailler
et justement c'est ce qu'on va voir
maintenant
[Musique]
bon alors vous vous en doutez mais je ne
vais pas pouvoir vous résumer 40 ans de
travaux sociologiques en cinq minutes du
coup je vais simplement essayer de vous
retracer dans les grandes lignes
quelques ouvrages et quelques concepts
principaux pour bourdieu la sociologie
est une science qui doit expliquer le
monde social mais qui doit aussi avoir
pour but de dévoiler les rapports de
domination qui existent dans le monde
mais il va s'intéresser en détail à un
type de domination bien particulier qui
n'est pas la domination économique où la
domination politique mais c'est ce qu'il
appelle la domination symbolique et ça
il étudie principalement à travers le
fonctionnement subtil des inégalités
face à la culture il le fait d'abord
dans le livre les héritiers paru en 1966
puis dans la reproduction en 1970 qu'il
coécrit tous les deux avec jean claude
passeron et dans lesquels il étudie en
détail le fonctionnement de l'école et
de l'enseignement supérieur
leur analyse part d'un constat qui peut
paraître trivial aujourd'hui mais qu'il
était beaucoup moins à l'époque à savoir
que bizarrement les enfants issus des
classes dominantes ils ont beaucoup plus
de chances d'accéder à l'enseignement
supérieur que les enfants issus d'un
milieu populaire étant donné que tous
les élèves vont à la même école
républicaine et qu'ils ont accès aux
mêmes savoirs tout le monde devrait
normalement avoir les mêmes chances de
réussir donc cette répartition inégale
des places dans l'enseignement supérieur
paraît à première vue inexplicable les
voies du seigneur sont impénétrables
et pourtant notre pierrot va réussir à
percer les voies du seigneur parce qu'il
va parfaitement réussir à expliquer le
phénomène en même temps il s'appelle
pierre bourdieu
pour résumer en deux mots à bourdieu et
passeron montre que l'école n'est pas le
lieu de la méritocratie et de l'égalité
des chances qu'elle prétend être parce
qu'elle valorise un certain type de
culture la culture légitime et c'est
précisément cette culture que les
enfants de bourgeois enfin pardon les
héritiers côtoie déjà à la maison et
surtout les sociologues insistent sur le
fait que l'école ne donne en fait jamais
vraiment toutes les clés nécessaires à
la réussite scolaire autrement dit la
réussite scolaire repose en grande
partie sur des implicite
tu crois être en train de respirer de
l'air c'est vrai que ça nous est tous
sûrement arrivé de nous retrouver face à
un contrôle qui pose des questions
complètement différente de ce qui a été
lu en classe et du coup ça bah ça
valorise forcément ceux qui n'ont pas
que l'école comme pourvoyeur de culture
légitime et al'inverse les enfants issus
de milieux populaires ils sont
entièrement dépendant de l'école pour
réussir parce que leurs familles ne peut
pas leur apprendre ce que l'école ne
leur dit pas au bon dieu vous sentez bon
la pomme de terre pour dieu s'est
d'ailleurs engagé pour une pédagogie
explicite visant justement à expliciter
tous ces petits sous-entendu de
l'institution scolaire pour donner
quelques exemples les implicites à
l'école primaire se situe souvent à
l'échelle de la métacognition c'est à
dire que le bon élève quand on lui donne
un exercice il comprend à la fois la
consigne mais il comprend aussi ce que
le professeur essaye d'évaluer avec
cette consigne par exemple dans ce petit
exercice où on demande de colorier la
moitié des voitures en rouge l'enfant
qui a l'habitude de ce type de consignes
comprends qu'on essaye d'évaluer sa
capacité à compter et à diviser par deux
voire éventuellement de visualisation
dans l'espace et il fera quelque chose
comme ça comme ça ou comme ça en
revanche l'élève qui suit la consigne à
la lettre mais qui a moins l'habitude
des devinettes ou simplement moins
l'habitude de se demander pourquoi on
lui pose cette question parce que par
exemple dans sa famille on prend
rarement le temps de lui expliquer les
règles il pourra répondre comme ça et là
c'est une vraie réponse d'élèves que
j'ai trouvé sur le site copies doubles
on voit que c'est parfaitement juste
mais que ça manque un peu l'objectif de
l'exercice qui lui est implicite un
autre exemple sur les formes de
consignes là on voit que l'élève répond
directement à la partie qui suis-je sans
faire le lien avec ce qui précède
pourtant je suis persuadé que si on lui
avait posé la question sous la forme un
espace moins 3 et 8 il aurait pu trouver
le chiffrement quand et là on voit que
la différence entre l'enfant qui réussit
est celui qui ne réussit pas ça se joue
pas tant sur les capacités mathématiques
que sur ben est ce que il a déjà entendu
une formulation sous forme de devinettes
à la première personne avec une question
qui suis-je donc la vraie question c'est
est-ce que ses parents lui font des
devinettes lui lis des histoires lui
offre des carambars bref l'ont déjà
familiarisés avec ce type de
questionnement avant
je vous mets quelques autres exemples
d'erreurs qu'on peut trouver par manque
déficit à sion et garder à l'esprit que
si aux primaires ça reste encore assez
évitables je vous laisse imaginer au
collège et au lycée quand il ya des
exercices de plus en plus complexes avec
des exigences parfois de moins en moins
explicite
bon et après c'est justement pour
essayer d'expliquer ce phénomène de
culture mobilisables comme une ressource
que bourdieu va fonder le concept de
capitale culturelle en empruntant la une
métaphore économique pour montrer que la
culture elle aussi peut être un capital
qui permet d'accéder aux places les plus
valorisées la vision la plus aboutie de
ce raisonnement sera publié en 1979 dans
la distinction critique sociale du
jugement mais qu'il écrit cette fois
sans jean claude passeron bon pourquoi
tu fais la gueule encore mais je fais
pas la gueule j'en ai juste marre d'être
toujours dans son ombre pierre c'est
vrai que les gens qui me connaissent pas
dans la rue ils m'appellent l'ami de
bourdieu c'est insupportable alors osons
claude je vois bien que tu fais la
gueule tu fais la gueule depuis la
reproduction je t'ai déjà dit que si tu
travailles dur et que tu te lèves tôt
toi aussi tu seras un grand sociologue
tu verras ah oui et aussi pas de sucre
de mon café 1 ça aussi je te le dit
plusieurs fois bon du coup c'est tout
seul que bourdieu s'attelle à l'écriture
de la distinction et pour vous donner
une petite idée du retentissement que ça
a eu l'association internationale de
sociologie l'a désigné en 1998 comme
l'un des dix livres de sociologie les
plus importants du xxème siècle aux
côtés au hasard de l'éthique protestante
et l'esprit du capitalisme de weber du
processus de civilisation des liasses et
de la construction sociale de la réalité
de bergen klahn donc autant dire pas des
petits clodo et dans son livre bourdieu
va s'efforcer de faire une cartographie
de l'espace social par le prisme de la
distinction au travers des jugement de
goût temps doux
mettons une cravate à pois une cravate
unis quand nous achetons une mercedes ou
une deux-chevaux nous nous identifions
plus profondément 1 au bout au fond qu'à
nos opinions et lenovo nous trahissent
beaucoup plus profondément que nos
opinions à partir de là bourdieu va
produire sa fameuse classification de
l'espace social en deux dimensions que
tous les étudiants en sociologie
connaissent et où une classe certaine
pratique et cette femme profession en
fonction de leur quantité de capital
culturel et économique on voit par
exemple que les professeurs ont beaucoup
de capitales culturelles mais peu de
capital économique et que ici par
exemple la chasse est davantage
pratiquer parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de
capital économique mais peu de capitale
culturelle et qui vote plutôt à droite
il faut avoir une
est ce que montre bourdieu c'est que non
seulement on s'identifie assez fortement
à nos goûts et à nos jugements mais que
tout le monde est plus ou moins
directement conscient de l'échelle des
légitimité culturelle même si on adore
harry potter on sait bien que c'est pas
vraiment la réponse attendue dans un
dîner mondain quand on vous demande quel
est notre oeuvre littéraire préférées et
c'est bien parce qu'on sait que certains
goûts peuvent être illégitime on a
justement peur de faire des fautes de
goût une de mes
découvertes en travaillant sur ce sujet
c'est que aujourd'hui il ya sûrement pas
beaucoup de jugements qui engage autant
les gens que les jugements de goût c'est
à dire vous pouvez facilement faire
rougir quelqu'un aujourd'hui de faire
rougir sur sa sexualité passage elle
plus en plus difficile mais faire rougir
sur deux fautes debout sur une gare
c'était extrêmement facile et l'air
c'est une des difficultés de
l'enquète parce que évidemment le
rapport d' enquête en rapport social et
la personne interrogée à l'idée du
statut social de la personne qu'il
interroge donc de ses goûts de ses
préférences et il a peur d'être jugé par
l'interrogateur est de fait bien souvent
ce qu'on appelle le bon goût assez le
goût des classes dominantes et pour
montrer que nos boues sont profondément
intériorisé au point d'être des supports
de notre identité bourdieu va inventer
le concept d'habitus qu'on a lui aussi
déjà vu dans une vidéo précédente à
temps c'est pas le machin avec la
définition imbitable la imbitable non
c'est simplement un système de
dispositions durable ensemble de
structures structure est prédisposé à
fonctionner comme des structures
structurantes c'est à dire en tant que
principe générateur et organisateur de
pratiques et de représentation qui
peuvent être objectivement adapté à leur
but sans supposer la visée consciente de
faim et la maîtrise express des
opérations nécessaires pour les
atteindre objectivement régler et
régulière sans être le produit de
l'obéissance à des règles et étant tout
cela collectivement orchestré sans être
le produit de l'action organisatrice
d'un chef d'orchestre
pour dieu le sens pratique
je ne sens pas bien là je crois que ça
m'a physiquement donner envie de gerber
ça fait toujours ça quand on n'a pas
l'habitude mais tu verras on y prend
goût je me permets d'en douter du coup
en français ça donne quoi l'idée c'est
simplement que quand tu évolues dans le
monde social tu hérites d'un certain
nombre de dispositions de façon parler
de façon de se tenir de manger de
travail et de te divertir et même de
voir le monde qui dépendent de ta classe
sociale de ton genre de ton lieu de vie
en gros de tes conditions objectives
d'existence et comme ce sont des
dispositions dans tu hérites tu peux
aussi les transmettre c'est pour ça
qu'il parle d'une structure structure
est prédisposé à fonctionner comme
structure structurantes par exemple si
tu apprends ton papa qu'un homme viril
ça doit jamais pleurer ni exprimer ses
sentiments et que cette disposition est
renforcée par tes copains les modèles
masculins et tous les films que tu vois
eh ben tu va intégrer ce comportement at
et façon d'agir dans son habitus aussi
bien dans tes façon de penser que dans
tes façon d'agir parce que du coup dans
ta tête un homme qui pleure ce sera une
mauviette père ça
de mauviettes et puis en ayant sa dans
tes gestes et dans ta tête tu participes
inconsciemment à la reproduction et à la
diffusion de ce schéma de pensée il agir
après je peux aussi ne jamais pleuré
mais pas pour autant considérer que les
hommes qui pleure c'est forcément des
mauviettes
oui c'est possible d'avoir un habitus
dissocier mais en général les deux vont
de pair en fait bourdieu distingue deux
dimensions à l'habitude il ya d'un côté
les taux ce qui désigne les principes et
la morale qui façonne son habitus et de
l'autre il y alexys corporelle qui
correspond aux postures et aux
dispositions du corps qui ont été
intronisés au cours de la vie et donc
l'habitude c'est à la fois la grille de
lecture à travers laquelle tu comprends
et tu juges la réalité mais c'est aussi
le producteur de thé pratiques et les
deux sont faites assez indissociables
parce que toutes nos actions ont quand
même pour nous un certain degré de
cohérence même si c'est pas toujours
conscients et évidemment ce que montre
bourdieu c'est que nos habitus dépendent
aussi en grande partie de notre classe
sociale
c'est pour ça qu'il parle d'habitus de
classe on n'a pas la même façon de
parler de manger ou de se divertir selon
sa classe sociale mais on n'a pas non
plus la même vision du monde où les
mêmes jugements esthétiques parce que
l'habitus c'est un ensemble structuré
qui a quand même une certaine cohérence
à l'intérieur de chaque espace social
toutes les choses qui sont mentionnés
là-dedans vont très bien ensemble c'est
à dire que le fait de préférer tel ou
tel cuisine n'était pas sans rapport
avec le fait de préfète hôtel nuit par
là on retrouvera tout un ensemble aussi
de deux choses parfaitement cohérentes
entre elles et tout à fait exclusive de
cheveux des préférences de tous les
loisirs et c'est là qu'on retrouve toute
la thèse de la distinction c'est que
dans cet ensemble de goût de mode
d'action et de façon de voir le monde
cohérentes entre elles et dont on hérite
à travers notre habitus on observe bien
souvent des logiques qui vise à se
distinguer les uns des autres et en
particulier de ceux qui sont les plus
proches de nous comme les bobos écolos
qui font tout pour se distinguer de la
vieille aristocratie économique
chacune au havre une
[Musique]
habitude un parfum de distinction
et elle le parfumeur qui ne confondrait
jamais de la lavande fine avec de la
lavande aspic ou du lavandin grosso ou
encore l'une des quarante autres
variétés de la vente qui existent
sérieusement je pensais pas demande un
truc compliqué en cherchant de l'huile
essentielle de lavande bref eh bien il
faut être prudent avec la classification
des pratiques sociales parce que comme
l'habitus désigne aussi une façon de
voir le monde ça veut dire qu une même
action peut avoir des sens très
différent selon l'espace social dans
lequel on évolue et même si on est
persuadé d'être ultra original on
reproduit bien souvent des stratégies
parfaitement explicables à l'échelle de
notre champ social et par exemple le
fait de revenir au bout jeans ou de
revenir à des choses apparemment
populaire change complètement de sens
qu'à temps quand louis est une non liées
quand nous les dégâts sur la deux
chevaux de l'intellectuel n'a rien à
voir qu'à deux chevaux de l'ouvrier
agricole jeudi que les gens sur la cl
infiniment moins libre qui ne croit
alors on lui a beaucoup reproché d'avoir
une vision trop figée de l'espace social
avec des structures qui se
reproduiraient à l'identique et qui
rendrait impossible le changement social
c'est ce qu'il appelle liste et résiste
de l'habitus
personne ne me traite
du coup il a par la suite beaucoup
insisté sur le fait que ladite us est
quand même une structure assez plastique
qui va se modifier tout au long de la
vie au fur et à mesure qu'on fait de
nouvelles rencontres et de nouvelles
expériences et en parlant de sa propre
expérience il en est arrivé à la notion
d'habitus clivé c'est à dire de
personnes qui ont plusieurs habitus qui
coexistent en eux comme lui un qui a
abandonné son accent et son habitus de
classe pour adopter les tos de
l'universitaire intellectuelle par
exemple on peut imaginer que si on passe
suffisamment de temps dans un contexte
de pandémie on va acquérir de nouvelles
habitudes sur les façons de parler de se
saluer de se rencontrer et même de
porter un masque qu'on aurait des façons
de porter le masque qui serait
socialement situer et qu'on utiliserait
pour se distinguer les uns les autres
du coup ça devient en quelque sorte du
corona beat us tu sors la bon du coup on
commence à avoir fait un bon tour
d'horizon de la sociologie
bourdieusienne avec les notions de
violence symbolique de chant de capital
d'habitus on voit qu'il met réellement
au point tout un attirail conceptuel qui
lui permet de penser le monde social
mais il ya un dernier concept que je
trouve assez importants à évoquer parce
que il va concentrer une bonne partie
des critiques et c'est la notion
d'illusions on ne peut pas dire et
régions comme tout le monde non c'est
bien illusio mais qu'est ce tu fais je
t'ai dit de sortir mais pas
littéralement aller revient on n'a pas
fini la wii non c'est toi vous sied pas
assez explicite mieux tu savais tout bon
non ce que je disais c'est pourquoi il
dit pas juste l'illusion il est vraiment
obligé de créer encore un mot compliqué
là oui c'est vrai qu'avec l'habitude sli
luzio les tos lexis bourdieu il aime
bien emprunté son vocabulaire aux grecs
et aux latin mais c'est justement pour
bien marquer une frontière nette entre
le sens commun d'un côté et le langage
sociologique de l'autre s'il avait dit
habitude illusion morale position on
aurait trop facilement pu les confondre
avec le sens de tous les jours alors
qu'avec lui justement ils vont en faire
des concepts précis avec une définition
précise
du coup c'est quoi cette illusion
alors l'illusion c'est le fait d'être
pris par le jeu social et de croire
qu'en fait il vaut la peine d'être joué
c'est en fait l'idée que les individus
ne savent jamais vraiment quelles sont
les véritables déterminant de leur
action parce que ils sont pris dans le
jeu quoi ils sont la tête dans le guidon
au beau milieu des mécanismes sociaux
par exemple un enfant bourgeois peut
être persuadé que s'il a eu la mention
très bien au bac ce parce qu'il a très
bien travaillé et donc qu'il ne doit sa
mention quinson mérite personnel et en
fait on voit qu'il a tout intérêt à
conserver cette illusion parce que
justement cette croyance lui permet de
se valoriser et par ailleurs moi j'ai
fait des études de sociologie alors ça
te calmes à la sociologie parce qu'on
voit quand je suis arrivée à la fac
j'étais convaincu que j'étais très
méritant est très fort et puis j'ai
découvert les voilà j'ai découvert les
travaux de bourdieu à la reproduction
sociale suis tombé de ma chaise et j'ai
compris que ballon j'avais juste eu de
la chance et en fait bourdieu montre que
l'illusion c'est justement ce qui permet
un champ social de se constituer le
champ scientifique le champ de
l'entreprise le champ de l'art à chaque
fois on fait comme si toutes les règles
au sein de ce chan était complètement
justifiée et n'était pas qu'un
assemblage socio historique de jugement
plus ou moins arbitraires
par exemple pour qu'un artiste soit prêt
à consacrer des heures à son art et à
persévérer malgré la difficulté et
l'échec il faut bien qu'ils soient
persuadés que l'art est la chose la plus
importante dans la vie c'est la
condition même de l'engagement au sein
du champ
et de fait c'est difficile de réussir
pleinement au sein d'an champ si on
garde une distance critique c'est pour
ça que pour bien jouer le jeu il faut
qu'on oublie qu'on est en train de jouer
le jeu
en d'autres termes on s'aveuglent
volontairement et on refuse de voir la
réalité sociale dans laquelle on est
inséré donc l'illusion c'est à la fois
une contrainte mais c'est aussi quelque
chose qui nous arrange bien parce que
c'est justement ce qui permet de donner
du sens à notre vie si on se pose pas
trop de questions et pour bourdieu la
sociologie permet justement de lever le
voile de l'illusion et révèle ainsi aux
individus la véritable signification de
leur action la sociologie vont
à une fonction je crois importante elle
dérange par définition puisque elle
dévoile et qu'on dévoile en quoi elle
dévoile comme toute science ni autre
chose que du cash et elle est en
dévoilant elle rend plus difficile le
fonctionnement de certains mécanismes
d'autant plus que ces mécanismes de
marche aussi que complètement que si
celui qui en bénéficient ne s'est pas
complètement qu'ils en bénéficient mais
ce positionnement ça va aussi avoir des
effets très concret sur la façon de
bourdieu de se placer en tant que
sociologue en fait pour lui le
sociologue ne doit jamais écouté les
justifications des acteurs sociaux parce
que justement ils sont pris dans
l'illusion donc du coup ils ont
forcément une version partielle de leur
action et c'est au sociologue qu'il
revient de leur révéler leur véritable
sens sans se laisser polluer un par le
sens commun des gens qui l'interrogent
et d'ailleurs pour bourdieu si les
acteurs sociaux pouvaient se taire un
petit peu et arrêter d'essayer sans
cesse de s'auto analysé celui ferait des
vacances oui je crois qu'il faut pas
hésiter à dire effet c'est peut-être la
malédiction de la sociologie et d'avoir
à faire les objets qui parle et cette
position elle va aussi être abondamment
critiquée parce que sa place le
sociologue dans une véritable opposition
de démiurge qui vient révéler les
ficelles du monde social là où les
agents seraient nécessairement aveugle
aux rouages de la société et donc au
véritable sens de leur action c'est
notamment sur ce sujet quand sociologues
comme luc boltanski qui est lui-même un
ancien élève de bourdieu va rompre
complètement avec lui en soutenant qu'il
faut au contraire écouter les
justifications des acteurs il écrira
d'ailleurs le fameux de la justification
avec laurent thévenot qui vient juste
d'être réédité cela dit pour bourdieu
tout son travail doit servir
politiquement ils font ce qu'ils
appellent la sociologie critique qui
vise à énoncer les mécanismes sous
jacents et inconscient de l'exploitation
et cela va se ressentir dans son
engagement politique
c'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant
[Musique]
bourdieu n'est pas seulement un
universitaire et un intellectuel il
s'est aussi beaucoup engagé
politiquement en cela il reste fidèle à
sa vision de la sociologie comme une
science du dévoilement qui sert à
révéler les rapports de domination dans
l'espoir pour lui de faire changer la
société donc son engagement commence par
faire de la bonne sociologie et pour lui
la sociologie doit s'adresser à tout le
monde pour permettre à tous de
s'émanciper c'est ce qu'il énonce dans
le film de pierre carles
le
sport de combat
c'est sur ce sujet
pour se défendre essentiellement et on
n'a pas de rush en servir pour faire des
mauvais coups et il a en grande partie
réussi à faire cela puisque ces livres
ont été de véritables succès et ont
circulé dans toute la population ce qui
au passage est quelque chose que je ne
m'explique pas complètement tambour due
à une écriture guy table je veux dire je
comprends pas comment on peut vouloir
propager ses idées au plus grand nombre
et écrire comme si on était payé au
proratat km² fait qu'il est né trop tôt
il aurait juste dû être youtuber en fait
t'es paris gym qu'on doit pas devenir
riche parce que justement les riches
tout l'argent et lille ils ont un et ne
donnent à leurs enfants tu veux pas la
voir toi bref on peut quand même dire
que de ce côté là la sociologie de
bourdieu a porté ses fruits comme peu le
montre l ouvrage pierre bourdieu
l'insoumission en héritage paru aux puf
en 2016 avec les contributions des
devoirs louis de didier eribon et
d'annie ernaux qui ont tous connu une
ascension sociale semblable à celle de
pierre bourdieu et qui raconte en quoi
la lecture de la sociologie
bourdieusienne a été une libération pour
comprendre leurs propres expériences et
notamment les phénomènes de violence
symbolique et de sentiment
d'illégitimité qu'ils n'ont pas manqué
de ressentir dans leur parcours violence
violence sociale
une bonne illustration de l'impact qu'a
pu avoir bourdieu pour un grand nombre
de gens peut se voir dans le film de
pierre carles quand il se fait alpaguer
par une militante au sortir d'une
manifestation
vous écrivez bien finie bas depuis 15
ans alors des moments j'adore
tout ce qui se dit maintenant vous êtes
bien c'est tellement médiatisé ça
m'énerve tout ce qui se dit autour de
jours tellement meilleur il ya quinze
ans je me rappelle je dis aujourd'hui
personnes connaissaient et maintenant
c'est la ridicule et
diablement intéressant pour vous
mais pour ce qui est de l'engagement en
tant qu'intellectuel on peut clairement
distinguer deux périodes dont la
carrière de bourdieu au début ils
s'opposaient notamment à la figure de
sartre qui était un peu l'idéal type de
l'intellectuel engagé alors à
messianique et capable de répondre à
tous il prônait au contraire une
intervention des intellectuels beaucoup
plus parcimonieuse et surtout des
interventions davantage fondées
scientifiquement et portant sur des
sujets beaucoup plus précis on peut plus
répondre à tous il faut répondre à des
questions partiel
délibérément constitué comme partiel
mais il répondre complètement vain aussi
complètement que possible dans l'état
des instruments de connaissances et
cette sorte de de redéfinition
minimisant ce vin de l'entreprise
intellectuelle et je crois très
importante parce que c'est un progrès
dans le sens d'un plus grand sérieux à
la fois scientifique et politique mais à
partir des années 90 il va s'engager sur
de plus en plus de terrain et on peut
finalement se demander s'il va pas finir
par se rapprochait justement de la
figure messianique de sartre luc
boltanski utilise l'expression
d'agit-prop pour désigner le bourdieu de
fin de vie qui prend part à tous les
combats et qui l'accusent même de
pratiquer une forme de terrorisme
intellectuel à l'école des hautes études
en sciences sociales ehess où ils
essayent d'un peu tout contrôler c'est
vrai que même si elle est parfois
réévalué aujourd'hui la fin de carrière
de dieu a été pas mal désavoué notamment
le pavé la misère du monde sorti en 1993
fera très polémique dans le champ
universitaire mais qu'est ce qu'on a
fait au bourg dieu tu es vraiment sûr de
cette vanne attend qu'on se mette bien
d'accord moi je suis juste là pour faire
des blagues quand tu commences à
raconter des trucs chiants 1 après moi
j'ai aucune obligation pour que ce soit
des bonnes blagues
bien nous quitterons la salle
en fait je crois que la date pivot pour
comprendre cela et peut-être
1984 et qui voit la mort de michel
foucault emportait par le virus du sida
j'ai l'impression et cette analyse de
mets d'ailleurs par personnel que c'est
à la suite de sa disparition que
bourdieu va endosser presque malgré lui
le costume de l'intellectuel engagé et
qu'il commence ainsi à prendre la parole
sur des sujets de plus en plus divers et
qu'ils ne maîtrisent pas parfaitement en
justifiant cela par le fait que si lui
ne le faisais pas l'espace médiatique
serait sans doute rempli par d'autres
personnes qui en connaissent encore
moins celui sur le sujet tout en disant
que je n'étais pas
détenteur de la vérité absolue sur ce
mouvement j'essaie de dire ce qui
n'apparaissait être le sens de ce
mouvement pour une raison simple c'est
que je savais que d'autres le dirait
qu'ils étaient encore plus mal placé que
moi l'image la plus connue de boer dû
engager et sans doute cette photo de
1995 quand il prend la parole au
mégaphone lors de la grève des cheminots
contre le plan juppé et qu'il se lance
dans un discours d'amour au service
public et à la main gauche de l'état
qu'il estime mise à mal par les réformes
gouvernementales
[Musique]
pour encourager parce que ben oui parce
que je pense était un mouvement
intéressant je voulais être il mourra
finalement le 23 janvier 2002 à l'âge de
71 ans d'un cancer généralisé des
poumons et il laissera derrière lui
plusieurs oeuvres inachevées comme un
ouvrage sur man et qui sera finalement
tu oublies en 2013 ainsi que son
esquisse pour une auto analyse qui était
pratiquement finie celle là et qui sera
publiée dès 2004
depuis 2015 on assiste à une publication
de ses cours au collège de france qui
sont reconstitués à partir de sources
multiples parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
tous facilement accessible en vidéo
comme ils le sont maintenant ce qui
montre que bourdieu n'a pas fini de
faire parler de lui
[Musique]
alors j'aurais pu m'attarder plus
longuement sur les critiques qui ont été
faites à la sociologie de bourdieu ou au
contraire sur les ramifications féconde
qu'ont pu avoir les notions de chant
d'habitus de capitale culturelle mais
peut-être vaut-il mieux aujourd'hui
essayer de dépasser l'opposition un peu
vaine entre les pro et les anti bourdieu
tu désolé qu'on a un débat intellectuel
ce soir kate moss se dire qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble c'est pas compliqué
je vais dans une salle de se payer
bourdieu et en fer et de s'en faire une
médaille ensuite qu'on le veuille ou non
bourdieu a eu un impact considérable sur
notre façon de penser le monde et cela
se retrouve jusque dans les mots qu'on
utilise pour y réfléchir vous ne parlez
peut-être pas tous les jours de votre
habitude clivé ou de lyster et 6 de
votre existence porhel mais force est de
constater que de nombreux termes
bourdieusien font désormais partie du
langage courant ou à tout le moins du
langage militants les notions de
capitale culturelle de doxa de violence
symbolique de champ social sont
effectivement très souvent réutilisés au
point d'ailleurs d'être parfois
complètement réinterpréter les vider de
leur sens initial et à titre personnel
je me réjouis qu'un plus grand nombre de
personnes aient eu accès aux armes
permettant d'analyser le monde social le
sociologue bernard lahire a écrit ce 23
janvier une tribune dans l'obs intitulé
aimez-vous bourg mieux dans laquelle il
nous exhorte à ne pas muséifier bourdieu
aussi bien pour en faire l'éloge que
pour en faire la critique et je rejoins
à 200% son analyse il est sûrement temps
aujourd'hui de dépasser bourdieu mais
pas pour le ringardisé mais au contraire
pour continuer l'exploration du monde
social qu'il a entreprises jusqu'aux
derniers jours de sa vie et je
terminerai ainsi en citant directement
le texte de bernard lahire on pourrait
s'inspirer de l'attitude critique et
créatrice qui fut la sienne face aux
traditions scientifique présente dans sa
jeunesse parmi lesquels le
structuralisme anthropologique incarné
par claude lévi strauss comme le disait
gaston bachelard dans la formation de
l'esprit scientifique
un philosophe auquel bourdieu aimait se
référer dans l'oeuvre de la science
seulement on peut aimer ce qu'on détruit
on peut continuer le passé en le niant
on peut vénéré son maître en le
contredisant
et de deux mythes vivants c'est
cadeau
cet épisode de ce classique est
maintenant terminée j'espère qu'il vous
aura plu n'hésitez pas à laisser un
commentaire pour me dire ce que vous en
avez pensé n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
activer la cloche pour être au courant
de toutes les actualités pour suivre
l'actualité au jour le jour où il est
bien sûr la page facebook d'ailleurs je
ne vous en dis pas plus mais va y avoir
d actualité très prochainement donc
rester connectés et j'ai profité de
cette fin de vidéo pour faire quelques
petites recommandations si vous voulez
en savoir plus sur pierre bourdieu il ya
évidemment mon plusieurs manuels
plusieurs ouvrages qu'on parle très bien
évidemment il ya ce petit manuel de
bernard lahire sur la sociologie de
bourdieu qui est très bien fait mais
j'aimerais en profiter pour mettre un
peu de lumière sur la chaîne de grégoire
simpson c'est une chaîne youtube de
vulgarisation sur le raisonnement
sociologique et on n'y parle pas mal de
bourdieu notamment au travail que j'ai
pas du tout abordé ici à savoir les
méditations pascaliennes mais aussi
plein d'autres travaux de bourdieu et sa
chaîne est absolument un bijou c'est une
de mes dernières découvertes absolument
fantastique allez-y sans hésitation si
en plus vous intéresser au travail de
pierre bourdieu il en parle avec
beaucoup de justesse en allant vraiment
dans le détail face à vraiment très très
très très bien fait donc allez-y foncez
sur la chaîne de grégoire samsung
simpsons thompson je sais pas je sais
pas comment ça se prononce bon bah sinon
voila je pense qu'il me reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter une excellente année 2022
peu de vous dire je vais prévu d'essayer
de faire un peu plus d'épisodes que
l'année précédente voilà on commence par
une grosse vidéo et puis on a plusieurs
qui devrait arriver bientôt cesser de
cesser de rester sur ce rythme là je
vous fais des gros bisous et à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]